raise your hand and be honest if you've
used the phrase crazy-busy to describe
your day your week your month I'm an
emergency room doctor and crazy-busy is
a phrase you will never hear me use and
after today I hope you'll stop using it
to here's why you cannot afford to use
crazy to describe your busy because when
we are in what I refer to as crazy busy
mode we are simply less capable of
handling the busy here's what happens
your stress hormones rise and stay there
your executive function in the
prefrontal cortex declines that means
your memory your judgment your impulse
control deteriorate and the brain areas
for anger and anxiety are activated do
you feel that here's the thing you can
be as busy as an emergency department
without feeling like you're crazy busy
how by using the same tactics that we
use our brains all process stress in
similar fundamental ways but how we
react to it has been shown by research
to be modifiable whether it's
emergencies or just daily day-in day-out
stress now contrast crazy-busy mode with
how I think of us in the ER ready mode
ready mode means whatever comes in
through those doors whether it's a
multiple car pileup or a patient having
chest pain while stuck in an elevator or
another patient with an item stuck where
it shouldn't be
when you know you're dying to ask even
on those days when you would swear you
were being Punk'd we're not afraid of it
because we know that whatever comes in
through those er double doors that we
can handle it that we're ready that's
ready mode we've trained for it and you
can too here's how step one to go from
crazy mode to ready mode is to
relentlessly triage in crazy mode you're
always busy always stressed because
you're reacting to every challenge with
the same response
contrast that with ready mode where we
triage which means we prioritize by
degree of urgency this isn't just a nice
way to get your to-do list I'm more
cried Akhter Robert Sapolsky shows that
individuals who cannot differentiate
threat from non threat and react to
everything with the same response have
double the level of stress hormones
which is why this is the first skill to
learn you can't take care of them all at
once but you don't have to because we
triage red immediately life-threatening
yellow serious but not immediately
life-threatening green minor and we
focus our efforts first on the Reds now
here this part of the problem in crazy
mode is that you are reacting to
everything as if it is red so start by
triaging correctly know your Reds there
what is most important and where you can
most move the needle now it's easy to be
confused by noise but what is noisiest
is not always what is most red in fact
my severe asthmatic patient is most at
risk when he's quiet but my patient over
here demanding that I bring her flavored
coffee creamer
she's noisy but she's not red I'll give
you an example from my own life last
spring my house flooded my 1 year old
was in the ER I was supposed to do a
fundraiser for my four year old school
and the final chapter of my book was
beyond late
maybe not ironically that was the
chapter on stress
my red tasks were getting my
one-year-old better and finishing my
book that was it remember relentlessly
triage the house flood repair well once
we had stopped and stabilized the damage
it was no longer I read it felt read but
it was in fact just noise no no really
it was quite noisy this picture on the
far right is me wearing earplugs to
focus on my book all the floor is being
mechanically dried around me no your
reds and do not let your non Reds
distract you from them by the way it is
liberating with a green task to every
once in a while be able to remind
yourself that's a green task no one's
gonna die it's okay if it's not perfect
now there's one last triage level that
we use in the worst scenarios and that
is black those patients for whom there's
nothing we can do where we must move on
and although it is gut-wrenching I
mention it because you each have your
own equivalent black tasks in your life
these are items that you must take off
your list I think many of you know what
I'm talking about for me this was the
fundraiser I had to step down because as
we in the ER know if you try to do
everything you have no hope of saving
your Reds step two to go from crazy mode
and to ready mode is to expect and
design for crazy half of handling crazy
is how you prepare for it so step one we
triage step two we designed to make
those tasks easier to do science shows
us that the more options we have then
the longer each decision takes and the
more decisions we have to make them the
more exhausted our brain gets and the
less it is capable of making good
decisions which is why this step two is
about finding ways to reduce your daily
here are four easy examples you can use
in your daily lifestyle plan plan your
entire week's meals on the weekend so
that when it's Wednesday at 6 p.m. and
everyone's hangry and requesting pizza
you have no decisions to make to get a
healthy meal on the table automate never
leave anything to remember that you
could automate whether it's scheduling
it as recurring or saved lists or
recurrent purchases co-locate when it
comes to exercise store all the
equipment that you need for a certain
activity together charged and ready so
you don't spend energy looking for it
and decrease temptations for anyone
driven by sugar cravings anyone say I go
ahead that itself is its own form of
crazy mode and self medication for crazy
mode but stop working your willpower
design differently if a food is out of
immediate reach such that you have to
use a stool to reach it even when it's
chocolate study participants ate 70%
less without thinking about it
I know let that sit for a second
designed to make the choices you wish to
make easier which brings us to the third
step to go from crazy mode to ready mode
and that is to get out of your head come
with me different story I'm working in a
small satellite ER when a woman comes in
in labor I realized that the cord is
wrapped not once but twice around the
baby's neck and I'm the only doctor it
was scared but I couldn't let it derail
me because you see we all get nervous we
all get scared but it's what you do next
that matters that first feeling isn't
the problem it can be an important sign
the problem comes we let it derail us
when
internal monologue starts and we
catastrophize and we start to get that
tunnel vision that's how you think when
you're in crazy mode and you cannot
solve anything that way now I promise to
come back to this story but first how do
I get out of my own head there are many
tactics that you may hear but for me I
find it best in the moment to actively
put my focus on someone else to
deliberately make myself see the person
in front of me see myself in the arena
with them what do they need what do they
fear and how can I help this may sound
like a whole lot of warm and fuzzy to
you but it's not in fact research shows
that when you prime your brain with what
is essentially compassion we disrupt
that tunnel vision and internal
monologue you widen your perception so
your brain can actually take in broader
information so you see more
possibilities and can make better
decisions try it know that your internal
monologue can derail you and realize
that when you get out of your own head
you get out of your own way now what
happened to that baby I focus not on my
fear but on the mother and the baby and
what they needed me to do got the cord
off of the baby's neck and a healthy
screaming kicking baby arrived just as a
dad ran in from the parking lot hi you
have a son I'm doctor Daria
congratulations you want to cut the cord
and for a moment the strong cries of a
newborn drowned out the beeps and the
sirens that are the normal sounds of the
ER but there was also something else
because when I walked back out of that
mother's room I saw several of my other
patients hovering nearby I suddenly
realized that despite their own problems
that had brought them to the emergency
room they had all come together to root
for this baby and they now together
shared in the joy because that is what
happens when you go from crazy mode to
ready mode others notice they want it
too they just don't know how they just
need one example which could be you own
the busy but stop calling it crazy
you've always had that ability but now
you're ready thank you
[Applause]